ces 8 a décidé de lancer sa propre
émission tellement fâché le joue dur que
c'est vrai parce qu'on sait on voulait
vous le dire voilà ce soir c'est une
exclusivité on va lancer c'est pas tout
à fait patron incognito mais c est un
dérivé je vous le dis de patron
incognito ça s'appelle appelé tôt
incognito s'appelle franck appietto
c'est patron donc ma piétons incognito
c'est le patron de la chaîne donc francs
capitaux qui s'est déguisée pour
infiltrer ces équipes regardent cette
semaine franck appietto le patron de ses
huit peuvent à infiltrer les équipes de
sa propre chaîne de télé bienvenue dans
appietto incognito
la production de l'émission va faire
passer le grand patron de ses 8 pour un
stagiaire afin de passer inaperçu une
équipe de maquilleurs de cinéma la
relique et franck à piéton et demi et
piteux de pester sur les vivres les
récupérer en badge pour entrer dans le
bâtiment
franck se dirige vers le poste de
sécurité vont s'en suivirent le nouveau
stagiaire mexicain mais plutôt comme en
évitant des béguines et elle s'y trouve
que vous êtes pépito arrive une fois son
badge en poche franck doit à présent
rejoindre le service dans lequel il est
en stage
la programmation où il va devoir saisir
sur un ordinateur la bid et aura un
prodige du tnp de la vague
15h tu étais numéro 10 de la rue 19
heures tpm p 23h30 fin de tes pmp minuit
gmt
le meilleur de leurs maux 00h02 fin de
tpm tu es le meilleur de leurs maux
00h10 gmt la chasse au sanglier et voilà
c'est la fin de la journée pour franck
mais au moment de quitter ses 8 il
croise vincent le directeur des
programmes
s'il le reconnaît c'est fichu bonjour
bonjour vous allez bien onze corps on se
connaît non non non je suis nouveau ici
écoutez maintenant on se connaît mais si
cette moustache au benhaim
[Applaudissements]
merci à
c'est très bien c'est sans trucage 100cc
mariage surtout fini fort forte de faire
faire ça aux patrons belle ils sont
jeunes et aux proches aussi patron de la
chaîne et on les embrasse très fort et
merci à eux
on les a laissé une mention légale ceci
est une parodie ou pour citer les gens
qu'elle exprime la pression que mal se
propage